und ich sage Ihnen genauso soll es
wieder in New York aussehen und das
trotz Corona und trotz seiner Inzidenz
von 3.600 ich zitiere wir können es uns
nicht leisten dass die Stadt weiter in
die wirtschaftliche Hoffnungslosigkeit
rutscht das ist die Begründung des
gerade frisch gewählten Bürgermeisters
Eric Adams ja das zum einen und zum
anderen behaupten Organisationen wie die
WHO
Europa ein weiteres Argument warum es
vielleicht gar nicht so abwegig ist von
strengen Maßnahmen wie unseren aktuellen
abzusehen wenn wir Corona also eh
bekommen warum versuchen wir da nicht
auch eine Lockerung wie in New York City
hier sehen wir nochmal das Zitat von
Hans kluge wir rechnen damit dass ich in
den nächsten sechs bis acht Wochen mehr
als 50 Prozent der europäischen
Bevölkerung mit Omegon infizieren wird
ja deshalb die Frage warum also dann
überhaupt noch die Maßnahmen unser
Reporter Herbert Bauer Nebel ist für uns
in New York und berichtet über die Lage
vor Ort
New York die Stadt die niemals schläft
New York die Stadt die niemals schließt
die amerikanische Metropole öffnet trotz
3000er Inzidenz alle Türen keine
zwei-regel oder sonstige Einschränkungen
zum Vergleich Berlin hat eine 800er
inzidenz- und in Restaurants kommt man
trotz Impfung nur noch mit Testreihen
in New York ist jeder vierte aktuell
krank die die können müssen arbeiten so
Bürgermeister Adams zurück zu Normalität
koste es was es wolle doch nicht alle
finden das richtig dr Paul Hazer
Gefäßchirurg spricht über die Lage in
den Krankenhäusern
es ist keine schlimme Krankheit aber es
verbreitet sich sehr sehr schnell
zwischen den Menschen es ist jetzt nicht
so dass wir viele Menschen haben die
beatmet werden müssen oder auf der
Intensivstation liegen aber die Zahl der
Menschen die sich infizieren kann unser
System überlassen und auch die
Krankenhausmitarbeiter überlasten
Touristen hingegen freuen sich über den
offenen Umgang mit Omicron sehr ganz
entspannt am Flughafen war es entspannt
und auch hier die Leute sind alle nett
ich glaube wir sind froh dass das
überhaupt Touristen da sind man kann
alles machen wir können alles sehen wir
sind keine große Reisegruppe und ich
denke
wird es uns auch nicht wirklich was
passieren eingekauft wird hier also ganz
normal am Big Apple geimpft oder
genesenen Regeln gibt es hier nicht die
gute Nachricht hier in New York ist der
Zenit scheint überschritten man hat nur
das maskenmandat verschärft und
natürlich weiterhin die Bevölkerung
aufgerufen sich impfen zu lassen so
gesehen ist der Big Apple hier relativ
normal durchgekommen durch diese Welle
es gab hier keinen Lockdown wie einst
zum horrorausbruch im Frühjahr 2020 es
gab
moderate Maßnahmen eigentlich kaum
Veränderungen zur Zeit vor Omicron New
York geht also einen anderen Weg
Hauptsache eins nicht schließen
ja bei uns sieht es anders aus harte
Maßnahmen im Sinne von 2g+ und vor allem
auch harte quarantäne-regeln das sorgt
vor allem in der Wirtschaft und in den
sogenannten systemrelevanten Berufen für
Stress zum Beispiel bei der Feuerwehr in
Bremen die musste nun sogar ein
Krisenstab einrichten unsere Porter
Gerrit Schröder ist nun vor Ort Gerrit
du bist in Begleitung wen hast du da
genau wir sind jetzt hier genau bei der
Feuerwache in Bremen hier hinter uns
wird also in ungefähr 15 Minuten der
Krisenstab der Feuerwehr Tagen um im
Grunde auch zu beraten wie geht es
weiter denn die Inzidenz hier in Bremen
liegt bei ja fast 1500 das heißt waren
Stufe vier ist ausgerufen und Bremen der
eigentliche impfmeister von Deutschland
ist plötzlich ein Spitzenreiter als
Bundesland mit der Inzidenz und neben
mir steht jetzt Michael Richard der
Leiter der Rettungsleitstelle und
Feuerwehr rette stelle hier in Bremen
und auch Pressesprecher Herr Richard wie
geht es weiter in Bremen wie sind bei
der Feuerwehr aus mit den coronafällen
ja wir machen uns Sorgen das kann man
nicht anders sagen wir haben ein wenig
Sorge auch dass die hohen Inzidenzen
auch in die kritische Infrastruktur
überschwappen wir sind da vorbereitet
wir leben jetzt zwei Jahre in dieser
Pandemie wir haben uns schon am Anfang
der Pandemie genau für diese Fälle Pläne
zurechtgelegt und wir leben in sehr
strengen Regeln gerade um genau zu
verhindern dass wir irgendwie in Gefahr
geraten nicht mehr in den Einsatz gehen
zu können also wir leben ganz streng in
Kohorten die Wachabteilung an sich
bilden eigene Kohorten eigentlich Rücken
unsere Löschfahrzeuge besetzt mit sechs
Personen aus das haben wir jetzt
aufgeteilt auf zwei Fahrzeuge einfach um
die Gruppen kleiner zu machen ganz
strenges Tragen von ffp2 Masken wir
haben bei den Freiwilligen Feuerwehren
den allgemeinen Dienst untersagt die
Rücken jetzt tatsächlich zur Zeit nur
noch aus einfach um Kontakt zu vermeiden
das versuchen wir an auf allen Ebenen
auch im Tagesdienst Homeoffice ist ein
großes Thema bei uns also Kontakte
vermeiden Personengruppen verkleinern
einschränken das ganze hat Wirkung
gezeigt das heißt die Erkrankungen
innerhalb der Feuerwehr sind
überschaubar aber man spürt sie oder ja
also wir spüren Sie also wir sind bei
der Berufsfeuerwehr rund 700
Beschäftigte und da haben wir derzeit
akut 13 Fälle drei in 13 infizierte bei
Personen wissen wir noch nicht was bei
rauskommt also wir reden jetzt von so
einer Zahl von 25 bei der Freiwilligen
Feuerwehr haben wir aktuell sechs
infizierte also eigentlich sieht es ganz
gut aus und ich hoffe dass wir diesen
stand auch so halten können wie geht's
denn dann weiter wenn jetzt diese
Infektionswelle auch die Feuerwehr
größer erfasst wie kann sich die
Feuerwehr darauf vorbereiten auch im
Ernstfall Rettungsdienst und
Feuerwehreinsätze abzuarbeiten genau das
haben wir vorgeplant also wir würden
diese Kohorten die wir jetzt schon haben
noch mal enger fassen also jetzt
arbeiten wir zum Beispiel im
Einsatzdienst im löschen und
hilfsleistungsdienst im
24-Stunden-Dienst in dreifachabteilungen
möglicherweise würde man diese
Wachabteilung reduzieren auf zwei wir
arbeiten in der Leitstelle derzeit in
zwölf Stunden Schichten da könnte man
überlegen auf 24 Stunden Schichten zu
gehen einfach also die dienstintervalle
würden größer werden die Arbeitszeiten
natürlich verlängert werden also würden
versuchen einfach dieses kohortenprinzip
noch zu intensivieren und die Impfquote
innerhalb der Feuerwehr scheint ja auch
hoch zu sein gerade sie liegen deutlich
über 90% bei der Feuerwehr oder ja genau
ich glaube das ist auch das was uns
jetzt gerade so ein bisschen an der
Oberfläche hält die gute Impfquote wir
liegen sogar bei 94%
deswegen hoffe ich dass es so bleibt
vielen dank Michael Richard für diese
Auskünfte hier direkt vor der Sitzung
des Krisenstabes hier in Bremen und die
Impfquote in Bremen ist ja ohnehin hoch
wir liegen in Bremen bei einer Impfquote
von 88 Prozent und die boosterung sind
auch schon zu 50% durchgeführt und
trotzdem ist Bremen eben ganz jetzt
Spitzenreiter geworden in Sachen der
Inzidenz
vielen Dank für die Einblicke in Bremen
Gerrit Schröder
ja wir sehen die Wege mit Omicron
umzugehen die sind verschieden die USA
machen auf trotz 3000er Inzidenz
Schweden war einst ja erstmal sehr
locker im Umgang entschied sich aber nun
dazu die Maßnahmen wieder zu verschärfen
in Spanien wiederum denkt man darüber
nach Corona nicht nur wie eine Grippe
einzustufen ja und auch wir dagegen sind
nach wie vor auf einem strengen Kurs
zweigeplus und das obwohl unsere Zahlen
von der New Yorker Inzidenz noch weit
weg sind schauen wir uns die aktuellen
Zahlen an Thomas du hast das Corona für
uns
[Musik]
ganz genau weit weg von New York aber
auch hier hoch das Robert-Koch-Institut
meldet heute morgen einen neuen Rekord
die Zahl der Neuinfektionen bin der
letzten 24 Stunden ist auf
81.417 gestiegen noch mal mehr als
gestern als zum ersten Mal die Schwelle
von 80.000 überschritten wurde zum
Vergleich vor einer Woche lang wir bei
ungefähr
65.000 dieser rasante Anstieg noch mal
hat auch mit den Nachmeldungen zu tun
die jetzt nach den Feiertagen erst
eingetrudelt sind die sieben Tage
Inzidenz
427,7 auch noch mal hochgegangen von
4007 gestern und
Todesfälle bin 24 Stunden in 360 in 316
in Deutschland im Vergleich zu 443 vor
einer Woche das ist also zurückgegangen
ganz interess auch in diesem
Zusammenhang die Aussage von
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach der
gesagt hat dass das Ziel einer 80
prozentquote bei den Impfungen bei den
erstimpfungen bis Ende Januar offenbar
nicht zu erreichen sein wird er sagte es
wird sehr schwer das ist klar bislang
sind in Deutschland
74,8 Prozent oder 62 Millionen Menschen
zumindest einmal geimpft schauen wir auf
die
hospitalisierungsinzidenz die ja
maßgeblich ist für die Beschränkungen
alles was über 3 ist dort muss eine
2g-regel gelten und dort wo es über Sex
ist eine 2g+ Regel da sehen wir das hat
sich eigentlich verbessert wenn wir
gerade hier im Süden sehen sind wir
deutlich unter drei in vielen grünen
Flächen hier dort einzige ausreicher
Bremen wir haben es vorhin gesagt der
Garrett hat es gesagt tro hohen
Impfquote von 88 Prozent die
Hospitalisierung Inzidenz dort in Bremen
sehr hoch das bildet sich natürlich auch
in den Hotspots ab das sehen wir hier
das ist Bremen ansonsten im Land
durchschnittlich wir haben es gesagt 400
ist die
Inzidenz da sehen wir dass sich das eben
auch auf der Landkarte so abbildet alles
in rot